[Music]
straight ahead
all law and crime daily the trial of an
iowa college student found murdered in a
cornfield begins
why defense attorneys for christian
boheno rivera are focusing on mollie
tibbett's boyfriend
you'd had a relationship with a woman
other than molly
right correct accusers take the stand
against that 70's show actor
danny masterson one woman's account of
the alleged rape
and the brave 11 year old who fought off
an attempted kidnapping
plus defense attorneys for robert durst
tell the jury he discovered his best
friend's body
but didn't murder her if not bob it's
not guilty
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmart along with co-host
terry austin
correspondent angina levy is in iowa
where the trial of christian vahena
rivera has begun
he's accused of murdering college
student molly tibbetts and jeannette has
the latest
yeah brian prosecutors say the evidence
in the murder of mollie tibbetts points
squarely at christian bahina rivera they
say it's his own words
and the physical evidence that showed
that he committed the murder and no one
else
prosecutor bart claver told jurors that
tibbetts went out for a run
on the evening of july 18 2018 and never
came home
tibbetts's friends family and law
enforcement launched a massive search
for her and even the fbi was involved
then claver says a piece of surveillance
video surfaced
that showed someone jogging and a black
chevrolet malibu with distinctive
features
circling the area that led investigators
to christian bahina rivera
at a local farm where he lived and
worked
and he admitted that he had seen mollie
the night she disappeared
he admitted that he found her attractive
that she was
hot in his words and he admitted after
he saw her the first time
he circled back to take a second look
he admitted that he followed her that he
got out of his car
she threatened to call the police and he
admitted he became angry
at that time he admitted to fighting
with her and then he says the next thing
that he remembers
he's driving in his car and he notices
molly's earbuds and he remembers that
molly
is in his trunk he admits taking molly's
body
out of the trunk he admits seeing blood
on molly's body
and neck he admitted taking molly into
the field
placing her face up and putting corn
stalks on her body
and then leaving
now prosecutors say that dna testing
showed that the blood in bahina rivera's
trunk
belonged to molly tibbetts but the
defense has disputed that in court
documents
meanwhile the defense declined to give
an opening statement at this time they
will do that later on in the case so the
state called its first witnesses
the the first one was jake black or jack
pardon me blake jack and his brother
dalton was the second witness dalton was
molly tibbetts
boyfriend at the time of her death they
were living in blake's home for the
summer and molly was watching the dogs
since dalton and his brother blake
were out of town for work dalton
testified about the last time he
communicated with molly while the
defense laid the groundwork to point the
finger at dalton for the murder
i had snapchated her but she had not
replied
okay so do you remember when that's when
you sent her a snapchat
i don't remember the exact time of when
i sent her snapchat
what time would you have gone to bed on
july 18th of 2018
relatively early granted how early we
woke up in the morning
all right and did you receive a snapchat
from molly that evening
yes yeah when did you actually open that
snapchat
the like the next day you'd had a
relationship with a woman
other than molly right correct who was
that woman
her name was jordan lamb would you tell
officers the reason you withheld that
information
i didn't deem it necessary you didn't
deem it necessary
i didn't think that it was pertinent to
the case
now on cross-examination dalton jack
conceded that molly was actually
thinking about breaking up with him
in the weeks before the murder and he
said he was not happy about it he was
angry and that molly was thinking about
moving in with friends
but prosecutors say that dalton jack
actually cooperated
with testifying in this criminal trial
he didn't want to come here though he
said he didn't want to be in the same
room with christian bohena rivera
brian thanks aunt jeanette joining us
today is founding partner of chr
law group defense attorney cesar chacuma
and terry austin
caesar false confession in arguing
against dna evidence
what do you make of the defensive
decision to not give an opening
statement at this point
well whenever it comes to dna or
scientific evidence that is the hardest
type of evidence
to overcome typically how that's done is
later on in the case by attacking the
methodology and bringing your own
experts
as far as the false accusations and the
confession we have to remember here the
defense has to try and attack the
confession basically saying that it was
coerced and involuntary again that's
later on in the trial however
the defense in waving their opening that
is typically a trial uh
strategy and tactic so you don't reveal
to the other side your defense and
specifically
what it is you want to do now however
the problem with that
is you don't want to wait too long to
show the jury what you believe the facts
and evidence will show
in the case all right so we'll see if
this tactic plays out maybe they'll give
an opening statement later on
terry what's the linchpin in the
prosecution's argument here
i think the prosecution did a very good
job it was succinct he told the story
but he asked the jury to remember three
things he said he wanted the jury to
think about the video and jeanette
mentioned
that there is a video and it shows molly
running on the street or at least an
image and it also shows
the defendant's car so the prosecution
also said they
want the jury to remember molly's blood
it was found in the trunk of the car
that was the second thing
and the third thing was the fact that
the defendants admitted
so much he admitted that he was you know
following her he admitted that he
thought she was quote-unquote hot so
the prosecution i think is focusing on
those three areas
it makes a lot of sense when he holds
the case together and jeanette
we expect to see the evidence soon that
led the investigators
to bahani vahana rivera right
yeah exactly brian we're expecting to
see that surveillance video that shows
what's been described
as a silhouette of a person jogging
along the road that night in that very
distinctive vehicle the prosecutors say
that
it's a black chevy malibu with chrome
covering over the windows and they say
that's something you just don't see a
lot so
it'll be interesting to see that exact
piece of video and how it led the
investigators to bahina rivera
absolutely still ahead on law and crime
daily a star from the hit series that 70
show
is pleading not guilty to rape charges
plus the shocking video of an attempted
kidnapping
and the amazing 11 year old girl who was
able to fight off a grown man
you don't want to miss
[Music]
welcome back danny masterson is pleading
not guilty to sexual forcible rape
charges
this comes as one of his accusers
testifies that she woke up to find
that 70s show actor assaulting her
danny masterson is accused of raping
three women in his home between 2001
and 2003. jane doe number one took the
stand at a probable cause hearing
in los angeles she says she was friends
with masterson through the church of
scientology
on april 25th 2003 jane doan 1
says she went to pick up keys from
masterson's house she claims
he gave her one drink with vodka in it
then began to feel blurry and queasy
that's when she says masterson threw her
in his jacuzzi
his friend picked her up because she
couldn't walk and masterson carried her
up to his bedroom
she described masterson touching her as
she lost consciousness
too weak to fight back she says he raped
her on his bed
but only has flashes of memory in
between tears
she told the court quote when i came to
he was on top of me and he was inside of
me
the first thing i recall is grabbing his
hair to pull him off
she also claims masterson pulled out a
gun and threatened her
on cross-examination masterson's defense
attorney asked why hadn't a gun been
mentioned
in her original police report the
defense also asked her about a
settlement and non-disclosure agreement
she's reported to have reached with
masterson the woman says the church of
scientology pressured her not to report
the rape
but she did file a police report 14
months later the lapd
closed the investigation saying more
women needed to come forward to
corroborate her story
two more women did in 2016 and masterson
was arrested
last year outside of court masterson
posted this photo on instagram with his
wife
the caption reads had the most beautiful
uber driver dropped me off at school
today
tagging the courthouse as his location
the hearing is expected to last
for days all right let's bring back
defense attorney cesar chacuma and terry
austin
terry this is just a preliminary hearing
so all the prosecution has to prove
is probable cause but do you see that
and maybe a little more
oh i definitely see probable cause here
i mean courts usually find that when
there's a reasonable basis
for believing that a crime could have
been committed and here we have that
we have three jane does and they're all
testifying that
he sexually assaulted them and this
particular
jane doe she had significant evidence
as far as her testimony was concerned
she signed a police report
and she also had other information in
other statements so i definitely think
that they're going to move forward here
they'll find enough evidence
yeah and don't forget probable cause is
one of the lower standards in criminal
cases
beyond a reasonable doubt obviously
being the much bigger one at trial now
caesar you've got a big following on
instagram i'm sure your clients use it
as well
was this post by masterson imc's
approved
no and let me start by saying i
typically advise clients
never to post or be mindful of what you
post on social media because
people are always watching and hardly
anything good comes from posting on
social media especially when you have a
pen in case
and often clients forget that anything
you post usually can be used against you
now specifically in regards to this
point uh this
this post i mean it appears callous
it lacks empathy and it's quite frankly
classless yeah
we're not saying he's guilty we're not
saying is innocent but optics is a big
thing when it comes to a case and when
you're going to a preliminary hearing
what a woman is talking about and it
sounds almost close to like a bill
cosby-esque
type of allegation that he gave her
quaaludes because she suggested she only
had one drink and felt queasy and
nauseous
not sure if this is the photo you really
want to show before you show up to court
but
we'll see how it plays out now to
florida where a local sheriff says
newly released surveillance video shows
an 11 year old girl
escaping an attempted kidnapping
a white van pulled up to 11 year old
girl
stopped the van looked around and then a
man left that vehicle
ran towards the 11 year old victim with
something in his hand that was poured to
be a knife
he grabbed her picked her up and tried
to carry her
into that van she fought and she fought
and she fought until finally she was
able to break free
from her would-be captor we were able to
see that van
and we also arrested the suspect and
this 30-year-old male
will be charged with attempted
kidnapping with aggravated assault with
a knife
so thankful that 11 year old girl was
able to get away let's check in with
chief investigative correspondent brian
ross with what he's digging into this
week
thanks brian coming up this week on
brian ross investigates
a 21st century crime wave tech savvy
hackers
kidnapping taking hostage the computer
systems of hospitals
police departments and now one of the
country's biggest pipelines
the colonial pipeline company says it
had no choice but to pay a five
million dollar ransom the country's
former cyber czar says
that was wrong i don't think we can make
exceptions i think we have to make it
illegal
for anyone to pay these ransoms and as
soon as we do that
they will go away that's coming up this
week on brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network brian
thanks brian ross coming up on law and
crime daily the robber durst trial
resumes after a 14-month pause
everything you need to know from the
prosecution and defense's opening
statements
after this break
we're back prosecutors say millionaire
real estate air robert durst
killed his best friend because she was a
witness in the assumed murder of his
first wife
both sides were able to recap their
opening statements but not without a
series of objections
he didn't kill her out of hatred he
didn't kill her out of revenge
he didn't kill her because he disliked
her he
killed her out of survival
he believed and this comes from his
mouth
that in the end it was her
or me i had no
choice and what the evidence is going to
show
is that you can fault mr durst for
the murderous nature of his conduct with
susan berman
but what you can't fault him for is from
his perspective
the necessity of having done it
the problem the evidence is going to
show with the murder of susan berman
is that mr durst committed that murder
about 20 years too late
because susan berman had already told
her story
to numerous people
in his opening the investigation in new
york was so far
i think that yes that was an argument
and it was uh
and the objection was sustained to that
calling it subpar as a characterization
now saying uh there are other ways to to
go about it
it's a fine line that's an argument you
know i would just say that my
my memory of my statement was the
evidence will show that the
investigation was subpar
that's what the evidence will show i
mean your honor the evidence will show
that that
the leading i o leo slept with a witness
um i mean that's what the evidence is
going to be
very well i mean to me i mean that i i
noticed that one that wasn't the one
that bothered me really
but i i do think that is fairly
described as an argument
here with us is defense attorney cesar
chacuma and co-host terry austin
terry things got a little heated in this
case early on do you think it will
continue when durst takes the stand
i do i think these attorneys have known
each other for a while they've been
dealing with this case
for over 14 months we know that i think
prosecutor lewin is the one who is
really very heated so when he does the
cross of durst
i think we might not see as much heat
because i think
dick degorin i think he is a little bit
more
laid back but i've got to tell you i
think lewin is going to go in
hard i think he's going to attack durst
i think the judge will probably allow
that to occur
unless we have multiple objections so
we'll see but they're definitely going
at each other i mean lewin did say get
your
your candy and your popcorn and take a
seat it's going to be exciting so we'll
see how that plays out when it happens
caesar how do you think the judge is
handling the back and forth between the
lawyers
look both attorneys seem extremely
heated at times and
especially with cases like this emotions
are running extremely high
however the onset of the case the judge
really has to do a good job setting the
tone not only of his courtroom
but the trial and although it appears
that he's trying to be tough he seems
extremely lacks at times and seems like
he's letting
attorney attorneys get away with a lot
yeah and we'll see how it goes because i
mean it's like any
started bringing sports analogies i
played soccer and if the ref doesn't
make the right call in the beginning
later on in the game things are getting
a little reckless we'll keep eyes on
this because of course
law and crime has cameras in the court
we've got gavel to gavel coverage
in the california versus robert durst
case make sure to check it out thank you
both
when we come back the other side of the
story was robert durst
involved in susan berman's murder or was
he just in the wrong place at the wrong
time
the defense is opening statements next
welcome back defense attorneys for
robert durst say he will take the stand
during his trial
for the murder of his best friend they
say durst didn't kill susan berman and
doesn't know who did it
susan got i mean sorry bob got to
los angeles
and he went to susan's house
the front door is locked nobody answered
he went around to the side
and the back door was open and he went
in and he found
susan's body but before he
left and drove back up to san francisco
he wrote a note an anonymous note
and sent it to the beverly hills police
for years he denied writing the note
it's so obvious if you've ever seen
bob's handwriting
that that's bob's handwriting and so
he'll tell you
i was afraid that she would lay there
for days
and nobody would find her and i
so i wrote that note i sent it to the
police
the defense attorneys say this is a
purely circumstantial case
and that prosecutors failed to prove who
the real killer is
the evidence is lacking the evidence
will show
that there was not a fingerprint that
bob found
there was not a hand print there was no
dna
there's no blood of bob no gun
there is no evidence no forensic
evidence
none that bob durst killed susan berman
was she murdered yes
who did it that's not our burden that's
not your burden
the state's burden the prosecution's
burden
is to prove who did it beyond a
reasonable doubt
it's not a process of elimination it's
not
if not bob who did it it's if not
bob it's not guilty
let's bring in cesar and terry one last
time caesar called me crazy but the
defense's argument
if you can't prove the crime you can't
prove the cover-up
makes sense to me what do you think
you're not crazy at all exactly that if
you can't prove the crime you can't
prove the cover-up
the state has to present evidence right
so here
although they're trying to use it the
disappearance of his wife
as motive for the cover-up let's be real
here he has not been charged
with the murder of his wife there we
don't even know where the body is
so for them to try to use that or even
be able to bring it up matter of fact i
think it should be inadmissible
yeah it seems like the foundation of
their argument is somewhat shaky
if it's built upon robert durst killed
kathleen durst we'll see how that plays
out for the prosecution defense may have
an argument there
terry was there anything in the opening
statement that made you believe
derse was more than presumed innocent
well you know it's interesting i think
that the defense actually did a decent
job with the statement
i think the evidence against durst is
overwhelming but the defense had an
explanation for everything even if you
don't want to believe it he tried to
make a distinction
between the three individuals obviously
kathy durst
morris black and susan berman he said
with morris black look
mers black was murdered but he wasn't
found guilty there he was just
found guilty of destroying the evidence
and jumping bail so
for that he served his time and what
he's trying to say here
is that durst isn't guilty of anything
else there's no evidence against him as
it relates to kathy durst as we just
said there's not even a body there and
as it relates to susan berman there is
no forensic evidence so
i think he has a good story i think that
it's still overwhelming i think at the
end of the day the jury's gonna come
back with a guilty verdict but
he's done as much as he possibly can to
try to
see that his client is presumed innocent
until and unless the prosecution proves
beyond a reasonable doubt that he's not
yeah of course the defense attorney's
really holding tight to that burden of
proof
we'll see how it plays out for them
cesar terry thank you for joining us
and thank you for joining us here at law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you